أجنبي
أو ارتدائه مرة أخرى، من
المهم حقًا الحفاظ على نظافة البشرة قدر
الإمكان وهذا يشمل ملابسك
أيضًا، وتقول طبيبة الأمراض الجلدية سوزان ماسيك من
مركز ويكسنر الطبي بجامعة ولاية أوهايو إنه يجب غسل بعض الملابس
بعد ارتدائها
مرة واحدة فقط بما في ذلك الجوارب الداخلية.
وغيرها من الملابس التي يتم ارتداؤها على
الجسم مثل الجوارب الضيقة والملابس
الرياضية، ومع ذلك يقول ماسيك إن
الملابس الأخرى مثل الدنيم أو الملابس الخارجية
غير المتسخة يمكن ارتداؤها أكثر من مرة
قبل غسلها عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالبيجامات التي تعتمد على نوع ملابسك.
إذا كنت شخصًا يميل إلى
التعرق ليلاً ويميل إلى الدفء أو
يحب الدفء تحت كل تلك
البطانيات، فقد ترغب في غسل
بيجاماتك كل ليلة، ستعرف أن
الوقت قد حان لغسل الملابس إذا لاحظت
بقع العرق  الأوساخ أو الرائحة، وعندما
تغسل ملابسك،
يوصي المصطكي باستخدام المنظفات الخالية من العطور
والصابون العطري الذي يمكن أن يهيج الجلد،
وتجنب منعمات الأقمشة وأوراق التجفيف
على الرغم من أنها رائعة في فصل الشتاء
لتقليل الكهرباء الساكنة التي ستزيد في الواقع من
احتمالية أن تكون
حساسًا وتسبب  الطفح الجلدي إذا كنت تعاني من
حساسية أو حساسية تجاه تلك المنتجات
من أجل الصحة، أنا آندي جايثر